right time for today's bartsch on how
low could all go if OPEC is really
trying to shake how these US shale
producers what sort of levels are we
talking about there's a bloomberg news
story today the title is oil at forty
dollars possible as market transforms
Caracas to Tehran if you've got access
to the bloom we do to bloomberg com you
can find that story the reasoning behind
the headline is this production can
continue to flow until prices fall below
the day-to-day costs at existing worlds
now Paul Stevens from Chatham House he
says some US shale producers may break
even at forty dollars a barrel or less
the IEA estimates that most drilling in
the back and formation which is the
shale producers that OPEC seeks to drive
out of business return cash at forty two
dollars a barrel so that's why the title
this story is oil at forty dollars
possible let's check out Brent crude
since the beginning of 2014 it's pretty
clear what's been happening since the
middle of the year today falling to
sixty eight dollars a barrel see that
yellow circle that's the last three
trading days in the last three trading
days since OPEC on Thursday kept
production unchanged oil is fallen over
twelve percent in November oil declined
by eighteen percent biggest monthly for
since October 2008 since its closing hi
there the green circle on june the 19th
which was a hundred and fifteen dollars
that was a nine-month high by the way
brent has sunk from there to there forty
percent forty percent decline lowest
level since october 2007 here to date
since the beginning of the year oil is
down by 38% worst year since 2008 and
don't forget what happened in 2008 oil
peaked at 147 dollars 50 on sep tember
the 30th three months later it was a $36
20 that shows you how fast and how far
oil could go in a short space of time
I don't want to just finish off with
what happened in the 1980s oils crashed
that decade was brought on by a
saudi-led decision to defend its market
share does that sound familiar crude in
the 1980s fell as low as twelve dollars
a barrel it's the question everybody's
asking how low can all go